[Musica]
questa è una navigazione effettuata lo
scorso maggio nel mediterraneo su una
barca che ospita un progetto di ricerca
sulla navigazione low tech e sui fattori
umani nella navigazione barca si chiama
claire onia navigazione low tech ma in
questa situazione la barca sta navigando
con il pilota automatico sta navigando
con una rotta che è stata determinata da
gps e come potete vedere se non ci
fossero pilota automatico gps dovremo
passare molto tempo a cercare di
interpretare gli aspetti dell'ambiente
che ci possono aiutare a sopravvivere in
mare io voglio parlare del mare e degli
aspetti di avventura e di conoscenza del
mare del modo in cui questi sono legati
il mare è un grande spazio di libertà
c'è molta letteratura su questo c'è
molta memorialistica e fare un esempio
francese
berna notizie la lunga rotta 1969
una tesi è in testa a una regata intorno
al mondo la golden globe race arriva al
capo horn lo doppia potrebbe puntare
verso nord per raggiungere l'inghilterra
è vincere ma sceglie la libertà alla
vittoria preferisce la libertà alla
vittoria punta verso est doppia una
seconda volta il capo di buona speranza
e riparte per una nuova circo
navigazione per salvare la propria anima
dice
potrebbe andare avanti il definitamente
la barca a vela offre questa possibilità
rispetto a una barca a motore che deve
rifornire di carburante e devi diventare
tanto più grande quanto chi vuole andare
lontano
la barca a vela ha un limite che
semplicemente quello dell'usura del
materiale e dell'usura dell'equipaggio
cosa sappiamo delle capacità di
resistenza degli esseri umani in mare un
altro esempio francese alain bombard
1952 bomber e medico biologo praticante
in un ospedale bretone in cui arrivano
continuamente i corpi di marinai che
sono naufragati che sono stati ripescati
dopo il naufragio e si pone una domanda
molto semplice
cosa ha fatto sì che queste persone non
potessero sopravvivere fino all'arrivo
dei soccorsi perché comunque l'abbiamo
ripescate e cosa fa bombard cerca di
dimostrare quello che oggi si chiama una
concept cerca di dimostrare che è
possibile sopravvivere in mare per un
lunghissimo periodo attraversa
l'atlantico su un piccolo gommone di 4
metri con una vela optimist in 65 giorni
senza acqua e viveri si procura da
mangiare pescando si procura ad avere
spremendo i pesci si procura le vitamine
raccogliendo il plancton allora queste
due storie sono storie che ci parlano di
avventure ma ci parlano anche di un
grande desiderio di conoscenza di
conoscenza del mare e io vorrei partire
anche inaugurando questo ciclo sulla
rete rotto pia sull'altro ve proponendo
una semplice misura misura di quanto
distante sia il mare dal luogo che c è
più familiare lo che c'è più familiare
in fondo ci dice che cos'è la teoria
dell'evoluzione che ci situa sito ai
nostri antenati in un ambiente solido su
cui si può camminare un ambiente stabile
in cui ci sono corsi d'acqua in cui ci
riparo dal sole dal vento in cui ci sono
punti di riferimento lontani
all'orizzonte per orientarci
il mare è l'immagine in negativo di
tutto questo è il vero altrove perché è
liquido ma l'acqua non è potabile e
instabile non ci riparo dal vento il
vento soffia sul mare crea delle onde
che sono grandi come colline non c'è
riparo dal sole e i punti di riferimento
montani non ci sono o quando ci sono
sono illusori allora cosa spinge le
persone cosa ha spinto le persone in per
millenni ad andare per mare e questa
domanda bisogna porselo perché bisogna
spiegare come è stato possibile che la
nostra specie potesse colonizzare tutte
le isole organizzabili del pianeta
praticamente senza eccezione alcune di
queste isole sono sotto l'orizzonte
molte sono migliaia di chilometri di
distanza dalla terra più vicina
io dirigo un laboratorio all'interfaccia
tra filosofia e scienze umane scienze
cognitive
non ci poniamo specificamente il
problema del mare ma ci poniamo dei
problemi che sono legati alla
spiegazione del comportamento umano
perché le persone fanno certe cose
perché le fan e in un certo modo al mio
ho lanciato questa domanda sul perché
lanciarsi nell'avventura marina ai miei
biologi del laboratorio e loro mi ha
detto guarda roberto si sottovaluta
molto spesso quando si trattano problemi
come questo le norme variabilità
individuale che c'è nella specie umana e
che c'è in molte altre specie verrebbe
il tè individuale significa per esempio
che ci sono dei comportamenti filo patri
c di persone che tendono a riprodursi
nel luogo in cui sono nati invece
comportamenti disperdenti di persone che
per riprodursi vogliono andare altrove
ci sono persone che quando arrivano
davanti alla spiaggia la vedono nel mare
un limite e ci sono persone che quando
invece arrivano in quel punto vedono nel
mare una possibilità e la differenza
individuale tra i due differenze
individuali tra questi tipi di persone
spiega perché alcuni si avventurano per
fermare però manca una spiegazione
supplementare tutto questo che è perché
esiste questa diversità perché esiste
questa diversità tra coloro che sono
pronti per l'avventura e coloro che
invece preferiscono restare nel luogo in
cui sono nati e qui la risposta ci viene
data da un'analisi dell'ambiente
il nostro ambiente è fatto di mare che
produce la sfida mai fatto anche di
isole che ricompensano questa sfida se
non ci fossero le isole i comportamenti
disperdenti verrebbero contro
selezionati e resterebbero soltanto le
persone che vogliono restare a casa e
questo è contro e non è contrario all
utilità perché poter emigrare permette
di trovare una soluzione di scorta per
la nostra specie quando l'ambiente in
cui siamo nati diventa inevitabile
questa è la semplice risposta biologica
però io sono un filosofo e mi interessa
anche capire qual è la fenomenologia di
questo altrove cioè cosa infilerà
dall'interno
l'esperienza di una alterità così
radicale come quella del mare sono un
filosofo con una componente pragmatica e
mi piace molto mettermi in situazione
l'ho fatto in diversi casi ho studiato
come si vive in un ambiente molto freddo
e un paio di anni fa ho fatto anche una
traversata atlantica a vela non sono un
grande sportivo lo dico subito ho fatto
le mie attraversato a piedi in
bicicletta ea vela però da quando ho
cominciato a navigare a vela ho sentito
questo desiderio molto importante di
fare una grande traversata atlantica che
quello che ho fatto e appunto in una
condizione un po particolare in quella
che si chiama una un ritorno atlantico
partendo dai caraibi e andando verso le
azzorre
purtroppo atlantico delle complessità
bisogna uscire dai venti contrari dagli
alisei andando verso nord come in queste
sequenze e poi bisogna fare unica virata
e cercare di agguantare la coda della
depressione nord atlantica e non entrare
nella decisione delle azzorre
senza andare troppo nord per non essere
troppo bastonati senza andare troppo a
sud per non fermarsi c'è un gesto
sportivo in tutto questo naturalmente è
a me la vela interessa come sporna mi
interessa soprattutto come veicolo di
conoscenza del mare e devo dirvi che
questa traversata è stata una scoperta
molto interessante perché si parte da
una regione che la regione sub tropicale
che ha una regione sostanzialmente
equinoziale in cui il giorno è uguale
alla notte nei caraibi praticamente però
avendole effettuate in inverno siamo
passati dai dai caraibi verso le
latitudini e delle azzorre e si arriva
in una regione prossima quella del
solstizio d'inverno in cui la differenza
tra giorno e notte molto più marcata le
notti si allungano di giorno in giorno
in questa traversata e queste notti
sempre più lunghe contengono dei
fenomeni anche molto semplici potremmo
passare molto tempo dirà discuterne però
per esempio è possibile vedere il chiaro
delle stelle riflettersi nell'acqua il
cielo a questa distanza dalla terra non
c'è inquinamento luminoso è un cielo che
ci si aspetterebbe essere nero in realtà
è una polvere di stelle contro il quale
contro la quale le nuvole fanno delle
ombre nere in questo mondo completamente
diverso e molto difficile anche a
mantenere l'orientamento qui una parte
della mia ricerca che cominciata in
questa situazione è stata dedicata a
capire come ci si rientra in mare aperto
senza gli strumenti di navigazione i
classici chiaramente il capitano aveva
accesso al gps
io no ho cercato di fare delle misure
con sé stante queste misure si sorride
latte catastroficamente sbagliate non
ero mai a meno di 200 miglia dal punto
per questo anche per capire la
difficoltà di questo tipo di ricerca ho
avuto molto spesso delle allucinazioni
di orientamento per molto tempo
immaginato che le azzorre fossero sotto
l'orizzonte e potesse in qualche modo
raggiungere facendone salire dall
orizzonte e questo ha creato una ricerca
secondaria è un'ipotesi che voglio
presentarvi oggi andare per mare per
molti secoli ma significato navigare
senza strumenti di navigazione
accanto a noi ce lo ionio che là ci sono
le isole dell'egeo dove è nata la
navigazione mediterranea e questa
navigazione transatlantica crea una
comunità con tutte le navigazioni che
sono venute prima di noi e con tutte
quelle che verranno dopo di noi perché
la vela in fondo è una soluzione stabile
al problema di muoversi per mare c'era
10.000 anni fa ci sarà da 50.000 anni la
navigazione a vela ma soprattutto una
comunità con il tipo di conversazioni
che i marinai da sempre fanno quando
sono in coperta e devono decifrare i
segni dell'ambiente
metteteli dal punto di vista di un
navigatore greco di 2500 anni fa parte
ci sono delle isole sotto l'orizzonte a
un certo punto vede una linea di terra
ma sarà nebbia o è veramente terra
questa linea
finalmente si rivelassero linea della
costa ma possiamo scorgere le insenature
il luogo da cui siamo partiti e quello
verso cui stiamo tornando c'è la
relatività del movimento mi sto muovendo
rispetto al mare però la corrente forse
mi sta trasportando arrivano il luogo
nuovo le persone parlano una lingua
diversa dalla mia
mi pongo dei problemi su me stesso
qualcuno mi dice che c'è un isola sotto
l'orizzonte mi posso fidare di questa
persona allora tutte queste domande che
sono domande di conoscenza
a mio parere sono mi piace pensare che
sono state all'origine della riflessione
sulla conoscenza come facciamo essere
sicuri che quello che vediamo è realtà e
non è illusione come facciamo essere
sicuri come facciamo a fidarci della
persona che ci dice che c'è un isola
sotto l'orizzonte
io vorrei pensare che la filosofia
sia nata in parte della navigazione
la morale del mio discorso è molto
semplice quindi il mare come altrove è
costitutivo della nostra essenza di
esseri umani che sono esploratori ma è
anche all'origine della nostra ricerca
di una conoscenza affidabile che
all'origine della filosofia e vorrei
chiudere con due semplici considerazioni
la barca su cui ha fatto la navigazione
questa primavera
come ho detto utilizzava il pilota
automatico utilizzava il gps per
navigare
oggi è possibile navigare esclusivamente
con degli strumenti tecnologici e questo
significa che non abbiamo più bisogno di
guardare l'ambiente quando navighiamo
prima la navigazione era necessariamente
una richiesta di osservazione
dell'ambiente però se non abbiamo più
bisogno di guardare l'ambiente non lo
guardiamo più l'ambiente e quindi lo
perdiamo un ambiente che non osserviamo
più un ambiente che perdiamo l'ambiente
che ci circonda oggi questo potrebbe
diventare brevissimo tempo il vero altro
né qualcosa che è sotto gli occhi ma che
non vediamo perché i nostri occhi sono
concentrati su uno schermo e la seconda
considerazione
naturalmente io parlo del fattore umano
nel mare oggi come sappiamo il mare è
anche teatro di sofferenza ci sono
persone che lo attraversano per cercare
un futuro migliore in condizioni molto
difficili
io penso che una migliore conoscenza del
mare dovrebbe aiutarci a inquadrare
meglio a mettere a fuoco meglio il
problema di queste navigazioni tragiche
degli ultimi decenni perché chiaramente
c'è un problema politico sul quale noi
possiamo avere idee tutti molto
differenti ed è importante che ci siano
anche le diverse perché bisogna
confrontarsi sulla complessità di questo
problema politico c'è un problema
umanitario
quali sono le cause di queste migrazioni
e anche qui possono esserci dei diverse
soluzioni diverse che possiamo decidere
di mettere in atto
però al di là delle conseguenze
politiche di queste navigazioni tragiche
al di là delle cause umanitarie resta il
problema del fatto che ci sono delle
persone in mezzo al mare che hanno
bisogno di essere soccorse che hanno
bisogno di aiuto e io penso che mediare
il soccorso a queste persone oggi
significhi dimenticare o forse
addirittura negare tutto quello che
abbiamo imparato i molti secoli di
navigazione e di apprendimento del mare
e questo significa se ho ragione della
mia dimostrazione di questa sera che
stiamo dimenticando anche chi siamo noi
[Applauso]
[Musica]